if you would have told us in 2011 that
the third sequel in the Thor franchise
would be one of the funniest movies of
the year on its release there wouldn't
been a lot of reason to believe you yet
here we are with Thor Ragnarok earning
over 120 million dollars on its opening
weekend and rave reviews crowning it as
the most hilarious entry in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe one of the best
comedic moments in the entire MCU
occurred during the Avengers a movie
which apart from the Iron Man series was
really the entry in the franchise that
proved Marvel's heroes to be as deft
with their comedic timing as they were
with landing punches we're talking of
course about Hulk vs Loki specifically
when the green guy absolutely thrashes
the cocky Asgardian god trailers for
thor ragnarok teased the reunion of Loki
with Hulk the only Avenger who can be
said to have truly and humiliatingly
defeated him but while the to do team up
by the movie's end thor ragnarok was
originally supposed to address their
contentious relationship in a more
direct hands-on way with a hilarious
callback to The Avengers that reportedly
had test audiences howling according to
Empire there was originally a moment
near the end of Thor Ragnarok where Hulk
Thor and Loki all line up beside each
other before Hulk still harboring no
love for Loki unexpectedly punches him
out of the frame
the callback actually served a dual
function referencing Hulk and Loki's
past encounter while mirroring a similar
sucker punch Hulk once pulled on Thor
director Tyco ytt says viewers loved the
moment but it was ultimately cut for the
purposes of time evidently it made
people laugh a little too hard
dear ailing the momentum of the scene
ytt explained the content of the missing
scene to Empire they all land on the
bridge Thor Loki and then Hulk they
stand for a second then Hulk just
smashes Loki punches him out of the
frame just like in Avengers when Hulk
did it to Thor
it was a crowd favorite but we just had
to get rid of it for time it might be on
the DVD get your laughs in now because
when Avengers infinity war hits theaters
it won't be a light-hearted romp that's
for sure thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
you